[Music]
this news hit the headlines at the
beginning of the year Disney boss Bob
Iger announced that a sequel to zootopia
was being made this means that seven
years after part one fans can look
forward to a reunion with Judy hops Nick
wild Flash and all the other Charming
residents of zootopia so let's take a
look at the animated adventure together
and get excited about zootopia
2 the setting of the first movie was a
huge City populated by animals the main
characters of the story are Judy cops an
ambitious rabbit lady who wants to
realize her dream of becoming a police
officer and Nick wild a cunning Fox with
a pinch it for shady deals the unlikely
pair meet by chance and together uncover
a dark plot by the deputy mayor who is
turning innocent animals into wild
beasts during their investigation Judy
and Nick not only overcome prejudices
but also develop an unexpected
friendship the movie deals with serious
subjects such as mistrust and
cooperation between different groups
while at the same time being incredibly
funny and really making the most of the
animal setting the iconic teaser trailer
with flash the sloth alone probably
attracted countless viewers to the movie
theaters in zootopia 2 we get most
likely look forward to the return of
Judy Hops and Nick wild the exact plot
remains a mystery so far but it is
highly probable that the two cops will
once again be faced with unsolved crimes
the city surely offers enough potential
for thrilling Adventures the sequel
could provide further insights into the
animal metropolis and the relationships
between the different animal species
many fans are hoping to see more animal
districts and learn more about the
special way which the inhabitants live
together ever since the first Utopia
film viewers have been asking themselves
a somewhat tricky question are Nick and
Judy dating on the one hand the story
fulfills the typical cliche of a
Hollywood Romance the rebellious couple
who discover their affection for each
other through an adventure on the other
hand the two belong to entirely
different animal species it is doubtful
that the makers will stir up such a
debate about zootopia 2 just to satisfy
some fan fantasies however we can very
well imagine that one of the two will
become involved in a romantic
relationship after all that would be an
interesting challenge for their
friendship voice actors Jennifer Goodwin
and Jason baitman are expected to once
again provide Nick and Judy with their
distinctive voices there is currently no
information about any other roles but
the sequel will certainly introduce some
new and exciting characters after
zootopia grossed over1 billion us to the
box office in 2016 and won the Oscar for
best animated feature many were
surprised that Disney waited 7 years to
officially announce the sequel in the
meantime the miniseries Utopia plus was
released on Disney Plus in November 2022
this six-part short film series
introduced new adventures in the city of
animals and showed that there is still
great interest among viewers the second
movie will be directed by Byron Howard
and Rich Moore as was the case with the
first part that leaves one question when
can we expect to watch zootopia 2 the
movie is only in the beginning stages of
production so we don't expect it to be
released in cinemas anytime before 2025
what do you think of zootopia are you as
excited about the sequel as we are and
what are your guesses as to what could
happen in part two we look forward to
reading your
[Music]
theories